hemos hablado en varios vídeos de que
las ondas que nos hemos encontrado
cotidianamente son una perturbación que
se propaga a través de un medio las
ondas en el agua las ondas de sonido las
ondas que viajan a través de una cuerda
todas ellas son perturbaciones que se
propagan a través de un medio así que
cuando vemos que la luz tiene
características de las ondas una
suposición natural
es imaginar que esta luz también se va a
estar propagando en un medio aún cuando
este medio no sea tan sencillo de
detectar pero imaginaron que la luz era
una perturbación que se propagaba a
través de un medio y a ese medio le
llamaron éter lumínico y mucha de la
física del siglo 19 se centró en
demostrar la existencia del éter
lumínico y también cuál era nuestra
velocidad relativa con respecto a este
medio y porque ellos se sentían tan
confiados de que podían encontrarlo el
encontrar esta velocidad relativa pues
de eso hablamos en el vídeo pasado la
tierra gira sobre su eje y además
dando vueltas alrededor del sol y además
el sistema solar está dando vueltas
alrededor del centro de la vía láctea
con una muy buena velocidad y también la
galaxia en sí misma se está moviendo así
que tenemos un buen marco de referencia
para decir que con respecto al éter
nosotros nos vamos a estar moviendo y si
decimos que nos estamos moviendo con
cierta velocidad relativa a este éter
pues quizá podríamos medir la velocidad
de la luz en diferentes direcciones y
así poder darnos cuenta si es que la luz
va más rápido o más lento en alguna
dirección lo cual nos podría ayudar a
primero validar la existencia del éter y
dos averiguar cuál sería nuestra
velocidad relativa a este éter pero el
problema es que en el siglo 19 no
teníamos una forma precisa de hacer
estas mediciones nuestros instrumentos
no tenían la precisión suficiente como
para detectar algún cambio en la
velocidad de la luz en diferentes
direcciones y él
alimento que normalmente se asocia con
este descubrimiento o la comprensión de
si podíamos validar la existencia del
éter lumínico o no es este famoso
experimento de mickelson morne y estas
personas se dijeron bueno no podemos
medir la velocidad de la luz con la
suficiente precisión para detectar si la
velocidad de esta luz ha aumentado
porque va en dirección del éter lumínico
o va más lenta porque va en contra de la
dirección de este medio pero lo que sí
podemos hacer y es lo que hicieron en
este experimento mickelson inmóvil y que
yo aquí voy a explicar de una forma muy
simplificada
es decir bueno aquí tenemos una fuente
de luz esta es nuestra fuente de luz
y esto va a emitir luz en esta dirección
y aquí vamos a tener un espejo con solo
una mitad plateada el cual va a permitir
que la mitad de esta luz continúe hacia
adelante y la otra mitad de la luz la va
a reflejar vamos a poner nuestro espejo
con la mitad plateada así que la mitad
de esta luz va a reflejarse más o menos
así y esa es una simplificación de lo
que ocurre y la otra mitad de la luz va
a poder pasar oa continuar su camino
hacia adelante y lo que vamos a hacer
con estos rayos de luz que en esencia
fue tomar este rayo de luz y dividirlo
en dos pues vamos a rebotar estos rayos
con espejos aunque bueno aquí se supone
que estos espejos son equidistantes así
que lo voy a corregir
ok así está mejor ahora sí lo que va a
pasar es que estos rayos van a rebotar
este va a rebotar directamente así y al
llegar a este espejo cuya mitad está
plateada y la otra no
de este rayo de luz va a continuar su
camino aquí tenemos este rayo y este
otro rayo también se va a reflejar va a
llegar al espejo y va a rebotar en esta
dirección llega también al espejo con la
mitad plateada y esa mitad plateada va a
ser que parte de este rayo se refleje
hacia esta dirección también aquí va a
llegar nuestro segundo rayo de luz y
aquí abajo vamos a tener un detector y
ustedes me pueden decir a ver aquí
tienes tu fuente de luz este rayo de luz
se divide en dos y luego cada rayo los
rebotes de regreso y ahora estos dos van
a llegar aquí a este detector y que ganó
con eso bueno piensen que si existiera
el éter lumínico estas ondas de luz que
están en direcciones ortogonales van a
estar viajando con diferente velocidad
imaginemos que el éter lumínico no se
está en esta dirección y si el éter
lumínico tuviera esta dirección cuando
la onda de luz vaya hacia esta dirección
pues debería ir más rápido ya que se
está moviendo en la misma dirección que
el medio y cuando la onda va de regreso
debería estarse moviendo más despacio ya
que va en
acción opuesta a la que tiene el medio y
lo que hicieron mickelson in more lee
fue decir bueno vamos a ajustar este
aparato para que cuando estos rayos de
luz se dividan y rebote y coinciden aquí
si no existiera el éter lumínico
entonces tendríamos un patrón de
interferencia básico y acá me refiero
con un patrón de interferencia bueno
imaginemos que el rayo que está
rebotando
aquí que estoy poniendo en otro color y
que llega hasta aquí hasta mi detector
esta onda va a tener un patrón de onda
más o menos así al menos lo mejor que
puedo dibujar una onda longitudinal y el
otro rayo de luz que está rebotando
desde esta dirección va a tener una onda
longitudinal como esta
más o menos así y cuando se traslapan
van a interferir se mutuamente van a
tener una interferencia constructiva o
una interferencia destructiva así que
podemos tener algo así permítanme copiar
y pegar esto y dependiendo de qué tan
rápido o qué tan lento se estén moviendo
estas voy a tener un patrón de
interferencia diferente y vamos a tener
una diferencia dependiendo de cuál sea
la orientación del viento de éter pero
lo que notaron mickelson y morley en
este experimento sin importar en qué
posición colocaran este aparato
horizontal vertical hacia la derecha
hacia la izquierda siempre encontraban
este patrón de interferencia el patrón
de interferencia nunca cambiaba
coincidía exactamente lo que implicaba
que a lo mejor este viento de éter pues
no tenía ningún efecto no hacía más
rápidas o más lentas a las ondas de luz
y este experimento es
de los experimentos más famosos en
física porque es un experimento fallido
este experimento falló justamente esa es
la fortaleza de este experimento que
jayo y como fallo muchas personas
comenzaron a preguntarse bueno es que en
realidad existirá el éter
quizás la luz viaja a través del vacío
quizá no existe este marco de referencia
definido por lo que conceptualizamos
como éter lumínico y quiero aclarar que
esto no se debió únicamente a este
experimento ocurrieron muchos otros
experimentos más pero justo después de
este experimento cuando detectaban que
no había ningún cambio en el patrón de
las ondas y a pesar de ponerlo en
cualquier posición siempre se encontraba
con el mismo patrón las personas
trataron de diseñar otros experimentos
que pudieran confirmar la existencia del
éter lumínico quizá la luz se contrajera
en la dirección del movimiento o quizás
otras cosas lo afectaran
pero este es un experimento muy
importante en física porque comenzó a
mostrar que quizás no existiera este
famoso éter lumínico que la luz se
propaga a través del vacío y después
descubrimos que la luz se mueve a la
misma velocidad sin importar cuál sea el
marco de referencia pero vamos a hablar
más sobre esto en otros vídeos